[Music]
along with another installment from a
major horror franchise we've got a
horror fantasy series on Apple TV plus a
zombie themed spin-off with a fan
favorite turning a three cool about
Greek weddings and another season of a
popular animated space comedy it's all
coming up on this week's what to watch
something wrong with the school
something doesn't feel right
praying for Success first is the gothic
horror movie The Nun too this marks the
ninth installment in The Conjuring
Universe wow and is a sequel to the nun
which itself was a spin-off prequel of
The Conjuring 2. what I'm saying is the
universe keeps growing and that's a good
thing and a great reason to see this one
plus it's worth noting that director
Michael Chavez also helmed the sixth and
eighth installments in the franchise the
curse of La Llorona and The Conjuring
the devil made me do it so he's no doubt
finding his Groove another reason is the
fact that Sister Irene is back once
again played by thaisa Farmiga the
sister of Vira Farmiga who's already a
staple in The Conjuring franchise Sister
Irene travels to France in 1956 to face
off again with valak the demon nun demon
none yep no thanks and with a sequel
sometimes you don't have to look any
further than the original for a good
reason to watch which in this case
performed well at the box office meaning
the fans were into it and boom see you
at the theater
they told me not to go but
I didn't listen
she told me I had three wishes and
premiering on Apple TV plus is the
horror fantasy series The Changeling
this show is based on the 2017 novel of
the same name by Victor Laval which won
multiple Awards and was considered one
of the best novels of the Year by Time
Magazine and we'll consider that to be
the first reason to tune in the second
reason is easy Le Keith Stanfield if you
loved him in Atlanta and movies like get
out knives out and Judas and the black
Messiah which earned him an Oscar Nam
and here he is at the center of the
changeling starring as a used book
dealer whose wife vanishes leading him
on a crazy Odyssey through a New York he
didn't know existed thirdly the show was
created by Kelly Marcel whose impressive
resume includes writing films like
Saving Mr Banks and 50 Shades of Gray
along with creating the series Terra
Nova a nice mix of projects to prepare
her for this intriguing series
how did you come to be in France
foreign
off right into your viewing schedule
next is The Walking Dead Daryl Dixon
this marks the fifth spin-off and sixth
overall Series in the popular Walking
Dead franchise which is good enough to
be the first reason to check this one
out it shares continuity with the series
and takes place after the conclusion of
the original Walking Dead and perhaps
most importantly for fans is that Norman
Reedus is reprising his role as Daryl
Dixon an actor and character that
quickly became fan favorites we also
know that Melissa McBride's Carol
character will be involved in the show
in some capacity a third reason to jump
back into this world is that The Walking
Dead Daryl Dixon will be taking fans to
a fresh location as it follows Daryl
after he washes ashore in France and
tries to figure out how he got there and
how to get back we hate it when that
happens
we're having a reunion we're courted
Greece oh yeah
[Music]
and by Lee I mean
the whole family
walking down the aisle yet again this
week is My Big Fat Greek Wedding three
look no further than the previous two
films for your first reason to check
this one out the first is certified
fresh on the Tomato Meter and the second
while rotten did perform well at the box
office so why not give a third go-around
and Nia vardalos who wrote and starred
in the first two installments as well as
this one also directed this time too
what can't she do for number three the
story follows the portocalo's family on
a trip to Greece for a family reunion
and speaking of which that brings us to
our third reason to see this threquel it
was actually filmed in Greece that's
right after one and two were shot in
places like Toronto and Chicago this one
goes all the way to Greece to really put
the Greek in My Big Fat Greek Wedding
These Are the Voyages of the crew of the
Starship Cerritos we're all such a good
team we finish each other Phantom
equations
and finally get ready to engage with
season four of Star Trek lower decks the
first three seasons of this animated
comedy were all fresh on the Tomato
Meter with seasons 2 and 3 coming in at
a hundred percent so yeah that's 100 the
first reason to check this one out
secondly not only is this the first
animated Star Trek projects in Star Trek
the animated series and it in 1974 but
it's also the first Star Trek comedy
both of those things are great for the
world of Star Trek the third reason to
head down to the lower decks is that
with a fifth season already greenlit as
well this is part of producer Alex
kurtzman's expanded Star Trek universe
along with series like Star Trek
Discovery and Star Trek strange new
worlds all shining examples of how many
great stories there are to tell from the
final frontier
okay we did it five picks to help you
keep busy as if life isn't busy enough
already be sure to let us in your fellow
viewers know in the comments what you
did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to check out
rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay fresh